on poursuit la discussion on poursuit la
discussion avec Annie Samson qui est qui
a été responsable du dossier de la
sécurité publique quand je dis
vice-président du comité exécutif
2013-2017 administration bonsoir bonsoir
bon vous êtes parti aussi d'un comité
actuellement il faut le dire qui demande
des plus d'actions pour faire face à la
violence à Montréal un comité qui veut
de l'action qui propose des solutions
rapides aux trois paliers
gouvernementaux bon administration
le sous-texte de ce que la ministre me
vient de me dire c'est que que la
mairesse nous précise ces demandes puis
on va être là comme si les demandes aux
yeux de Québec étaient pas assez précise
pour qu'il y ait plus de policiers par
exemple on a compris la même chose vous
comprenez ça exactement on regarde on a
juste à regarder la conférence de presse
cet après-midi 44 minutes de retard
probablement qu'il y avait des choses à
fignoler mais pour une situation c'est
importante que celle de la sécurité de
la ville on doit être préparé pour
ceux-là on n'attend pas de se préparer
au cosu on se prépare à tous les jours
puis depuis un an ça tire de partout
j'ose croire que les mairesse a aussi
ses informations là pendant la
conférence de presse on attendait
peut-être des demandes particulières
précises comme la ministre a dit on en a
pas parlé on se chicane depuis quelques
semaines sur combien de policiers en a
combien qui sont partis oui il y en a
deux de plus 40 de moins le total
elle-même on se souvient pendant la
campagne électorale on a eu quelques
bonnes discussions là-dessus mais on
sait pas là on n'a pas plus
70 actuellement
la Sophie roi la chef éternelle dit
aujourd'hui on est dans une phase de
retraite plus donc c'est inquiétant
cette année bon alors ok qu'est-ce que
vous décodez est-ce que la mairesse
d'abord d'après vous traîne cette image
de pas être très propolis
c'est dommage mais oui depuis la
dernière campagne électorale où on a
parlé de des financer la police où est
le prospère comme candidat malgré tout
ce qui est sorti contre lui le fait de
désarmer les policiers aussi c'est un
des très très bonne idée mais pas
maintenant la meilleure des idées peut
devenir la pire dans un moment comme
aujourd'hui on peut pas parler de ça et
malheureusement elle traîne encore ce
boulet là à son pied et et de toutes ces
sorties les policiers ont pas encore
appris à lui faire pleinement confiance
et la confiance ça se mérite et
actuellement de la façon dont le dossier
de la sécurité est traité et traiter
comme n'importe quel autre dossier dans
les parcs les pistes cyclables c'est un
dossier mais ça devrait être la priorité
à morale
reste
de leadership dans ce dossier de la
saleté publique on ne sent pas que c'est
le dossier des dossiers à l'assume pas
le lit de Chypre qu'elle devrait assumer
comme mère de Montréal ça pour moi c'est
important lorsqu'on a un poste aussi
important on est responsable de la
sécurité de tous nos citoyens
là vous aviez fait des recommandations à
l'époque quand votre comité a été lancé
concrètement qu'est-ce qui peut passer
pas que l'attitude de la mairesse qui va
régler ce qui se passe à Montréal vous
aviez dit par exemple que les policiers
puissent faire des interpellations plus
librement que parce qu'on était on vous
aviez vous donner l'impression que les
menottait
les policiers quand lorsqu'on parle de
désengagement c'est justement dans la
façon des pouvoirs qu'ils peuvent faire
et des
réprimantes qu'ils ont aussi donc
lorsqu'on arrête un véhicule souvent il
s'agit de communauté là on parle de
profilage racial tout de suite en
partant et c'est pas ça quand quelqu'un
issu d'une communauté quelle qu'elle
soit ne fait pas son stock puis que la
police l'arête c'est pas parce que tu as
une certaine couleur de peau qu'on fait
du profilage racial c'est que la loi
elle est bonne pour tout le monde mais
actuellement les policiers on parle de
le faire parce qu'ils disent à partir du
moment où on essaie d'arrêter on va se
ramasser avec une plainte en déontologie
encore des outils politiques mais ça
revient à la loi de la police ça revient
à certaines modifications législatives
ça revient aussi à mettre des des
critères en cause le nous ce qu'on
suggéré c'est pas très compliqué c'est
de rajouter un listing dans lequel on
sait que cette voiture là elle a été
arrêtée trois fois durant la semaine
mais il faut se documenter le pourquoi
le policier avant de l'arrêter va dire
regarde il fait trois fois on le fera
pas parce qu'on va il y a des façons de
faire simple qu'on pourrait régler plein
de problèmes des peines plus lourdes la
mairesse à nous parler aujourd'hui vous
proposiez ça aussi le dépôts plus
lourdes que le système en général soit
plus sévère
qui est plus d'armes de pointe
absolument aucune mais plus que ça les
armes de poing là c'est les gens qui
l'ont enregistré c'est pas ces armes là
qu'on sert dans la rue c'est des armes
qui sont il y a les armes fantômes
celles qu'on imprime sur les imprimantes
3D mais il y a aussi le transfert des
armes qui viennent des États-Unis qui
passent par les comme ça par les les
réserves indiennes aussi et ça on a déjà
moi j'ai rencontré le ministre
maintenant donc le ministre de sécurité
publique pour lui parler de ça de
refaire refermer les frontières de
mettre une grande surveillance c'est
l'accessibilité des armes à Montréal le
jeûne qui s'est fait arrêter avec 250
armes mais la loi fait quoi dis-moi
après ça sort de la prison quel exemple
on donne à nos jeunes tour de vice
partout puis vous dites en conclusion
que la mairesse aurait dû arriver avec
quelque chose de plus structuré
aujourd'hui oui oui puis plus rassurant
merci beaucoup on va se reparler de ça
malheureusement de ce dossier là et qui
fera partie de cette campagne électorale
au Québec plus largement merci beaucoup
merci beaucoup